[Music]
Avengers endgame is on the horizon and
whilst there are many fan theories
flying about on the film there's one
that I haven't seen mentioned the air
that actually seems like it could hold a
lot of weight that theory ties into the
original infinity war trailer and is
something that though shown heavily and
marketing never materialized the scene
I'm talking about is the one in which we
see all of our heroes running towards
the camera as if they are all United and
facing down panels in the scene we see
an appearance by the Hulk Captain
America Black Panther Black Widow the
wakandan army Bucky
war machine Falcon and more of course we
know from the film that this scene was
never in it and it seems strange that
the studio spent so much money animating
and getting actors together for a scene
that would ultimately end up on the
cutting room floor personally I think
that this scene will actually end up as
a finale for endgame and is one of the
smartest baits which moves in movie
history
we know from leaked set photos that end
game will have our heroes traveling
through time to significant moments in
their history to take the Infinity
stones before Thanos is able to retain
them what if this time-travel culminates
in Our Heroes all journeying to the
battle of Wakanda in their final
time-travel move to face Thanos head-on
and defeat him once and for all before
he is able to do the snap the image
itself seems like something is missing
if you look on the sides and this could
be space for Doctor Strange ant-man Iron
Man and the other heroes to standing
perhaps they were CGI doubt or not put
in the shot for this moment as Marvel
have been known to do with other
trailers for things like Thor's eye and
the Infinity stones to me this makes a
hell of a lot of sense and would explain
why Marvel spent so much money on a
missing scene it would also allow for
the Hulk to gain some redemption as he
was missing from the battle on Wakanda
and in general makes for a kick-ass
moment that delay
on a lot of levels for satisfying finale
so what are your thoughts on this theory
and have you heard a better one I just
want to give a huge shout outs to Katie
Lee for messaging me with this theory
she's always talking on Twitter about
plan theories like this and pretty much
gets a bang on every time I've linked to
a Twitter handle in the description so
make sure you give her a follow to be
kept up to date with more theories like
this this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition that you've been
the best I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]